Okay.
We have a voicemail number two, one nine two.
David p.
This is a really funny voicemail.
This is meant to be a parody of some of the
really dim right wing callers that we get.
And I don't know if the implication is that
we, uh, are somehow specifically selecting
in competent right-wingers to pick up on when
we take live calls.
Of course, I don't do that.
I just see a phone number and I pick up on
phone numbers that I've not seen before.
Um, but this is so funny because it's something
about this.
It's like, yeah, that actually is, you're
not even really exaggerating.
This is what a lot of our right-wing callers
sound like.
Take a listen.
Hey David.
Um, my question is, uh, you know, about the,
um, uh, about the, uh, Chinese, um, uh, you
know, uh, I, uh, can't, uh, you know, uh,
form a sentence, um, because I am a typical,
um, David Pakman show caller.
Um, I'm a troglodyte.
I'm a virgin and I, you know, I wouldn't even
know how to go about, you know, even, uh,
forming a question.
I don't form a question before I call in.
Okay.
Right.
I've never formed a question.
I have a very bad connection.
I don't know.
Louis metonymy.
Uh, I don't know the fake beef between you,
between David, pacman and Dempsey.
I'm a total virgin, you know?
Okay.
Um, so my question is, uh, for someone, uh,
looking to get a better, um, uh, at the David
Pakman show, right?
Um, uh, you know, I mean, I don't even know.
I don't even know your producers, uh, first
and last names by heart.
I know there's a Max.
I know there's, uh, pat, I know there's a,
there's a, uh, you have ad agency as you took
angel investors.
Dude, I don't even know.
I mean, I don't even know where your shoot,
I mean, I, I think you're out of your mom's
basement, is that right?
That's exactly right.
Yeah.
But you know, for someone who's pretending
not to know a lot of this stuff about the
show, you seem to know a whole hell of a lot
about it, my friend.
But yeah.
Okay.
So troglodyte virgin calls into the show and
actually sounds like a lot of the right wing
callers that we get.
I don't know what we've accomplished with
that little experiment.
We've got a great bonus show for you today.
Twitter has blocked or locked rather Mitch
McConnell's campaign account because they
posted video of protesters shouting threats
and profanity.
Hilarious.
Barcelona has confirmed that women can swim
topless in city pools because of a gender
equality, um, uh, rule law, I guess we could
call it.
And, uh, we will talk about the contagion
of mass events, contagion of mass event, and
being careful about how I word that, uh, for
specific reasons which will become clear on
the bonus show.
Two ways
to access it.
Become a member at www dot [inaudible] dot
com or a patron@patriondotcomslashdavidthedavidpakmanshowatdavidpakman.com.